et
oui il ya pour l'instant on n'a pas le
son voilà mr alors quand ils sont pas
encore là wingen nîmes est ce son là il
s'agit de sanaa ce pas le premier sujet
du gps concerne le concert hommage à
johnny hallyday qui aura lieu le 14
septembre prochain de nombreux artistes
monteront sur scène à l'accord hôtels ça
s'appelle que je t'aime et on regarde un
petit sujet on en parle juste après vous
vous avez toutes les infos bien sûr
bernard montiel oui ça sera champion du
monde quelques-unes merci à regarder il
est meilleur là dedans que sur les
météorites vous aval
à l'accord hôtel arena ils seront dix
mille à pouvoir chanter les tubes de
johnny une salle emblématique du
chanteur pour reprendre ses classiques
des pointures de la chanson française
calogero pascal obispo patrick bruel
mais aussi gad elmaleh l'événement est
organisé depuis deux ans par laeticia
hallyday en lien avec la maire de paris
car la capitale veut aussi mettre à
l'honneur ce symbole du rock l'esplanade
devant l'accord auquel arena sera
renommé à son ombre c'est un cadeau
inestimable qui nous est offert à nous
sa famille mais aussi à tous ceux qu'il
aime et qui continuent de porter en eux
sa musique sa liberté la billetterie
ouvre ce jeudi avec des premiers lié à
35 euros et les bénéfices seront
reversés à des associations sauce alors
ça sera présentée par michel drucker le
spectacle a été organisé par laeticia
hallyday et il ya une petite politique
il ya des prix beaucoup de ses proches
manqueront à l'appel alors qui bat déjà
laura smet a été invités ainsi que david
évident mais mme david avait été invitée
à chanter en hommage à son père il est
parmi tes pour faire des merguez à
l'arsenal
de merguez
leur fils de johnny il aurait pu être
invités comme ça comme donc été invités
à chanter et laura à venir en tout cas
assister à ça tous les deux ont refusé
officiellement ya pas de problème
pourquoi ils ont fait des quoi c'est son
nom d'abord je vous dis une chose
laetitia ça ne fait pas du tout bougé la
productrice anne marcassus laeticia est
à los angeles elle s'occupa dans le
détail de la soirée où elle est en
revanche ce que je veux dire par là on a
invité par exemple obispo pascal obispo
n'ira pas non plus pour quel motif bah
oui ce pot il trouvé ça pas clair tout
ce qui se passait autour paradis or mais
c'est à dire que comme vous l'avez dit
dans le reportage que s'il ya des liens
se seraient reversés à des associations
déjà on sait pas lesquelles alors moi
j'ai les chiffres en revanche bon y aura
julien doré patrick bruel pagny luan
kenji ça va être énorme à toute façon ça
va
magnifique un c'est évident et chacun
reprendre un titre de johnny c'est en
direct sur france 2 comme vous l'avez 10
600 mille euros payés par france 2 il ya
135 mille euros de techniques et si
jamais on fait le plein c'est à dire dix
mille places c'est comme un est loin du
compte ça va rapporter 400 mille euros
et le spectacle en lui-même coûte un
million deux amis en quatre mois avait
suivi ou pas vous avez pas laissez moi
je suis plus
permis sur mille boîtes dans cette merde
là dedans je trouvais à imola perdu 800
millions exactement ils sont le savez
survivent à l'arc à 6 la productrice a
priori on gagne rien du tout sûr ni les
médias ni la mairie ni l'accord arena ni
personne voilà le rire acquis à ce
concert et biaggi un doré bruel pagny
lohan kenji
laura smet elle sera là le matin et pas
le soir ce que matin il ya
l'inauguration d'une nouvelle place
qu'elle a accepté d'être le matin mais
pas pour le concert d'accord elle sera
là pour l'inaugurer la place d'actes
manqués
pas d'accord
non mais c'est vrai voilà la statue je
vous en avais parlé c'est un engin de
type sonnent les guitares gibson et en
os il ya une heure les davidson suspendu
d'accord merci à
l'occasion occasion de quoi il arrive
quoi c'est parce que c'est la salle où
l'a été le plus souvent johnny il va
faire comme ça tous les ans qu'il a ça
coûtait 700 mille euros aux français
lassés 90 justement offert non alors
c'est important de dire et c'est pas
pour l'heure de dire c'est la france
doit donner 700 mines c'est un programme
mais c'est un programme de télé vous
pensez différents donc ils sont les 500
mille dinars et zon lesquels cinq cent
mille
six cent mille oui le concert écoutant
le coût des programmes de france doit
donner la moitié du concert faut balayer
la technique il faut payer la corde
rick parry
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas compliqué mais l'on mettait gonflé
mais ils sont comme l'engin en argent
hidalgo et tous les travaux qu'elle fait
dans paris celle-là je voulais vous dire
le plus important que la statue réalisée
par l'artiste monsieur lavier qui est un
artiste qui clavier
question regarder qui sera d'ailleurs
question clavier sera avec nous demain
disparition il ya expressément pour nous
je laime boucle artistes s'appellent
lavier cilic a créé sur terre et c'est
payé intégralement par le galériste qui
s'appelle kamel mennour donc ça ne coûte
pas un rond ni à la mairie il n'y a
personne il faut quand même le dire
quand même le dire là les gens
commencent à dire et alors mathieu
delormeau québec un responsable de
l'argent absolument c'est le 14
septembre donc dans quelques jours et on
sait toujours pas où va l'argent c'est à
dire à quelle association vos armes
c'est net c'est comme un peu bizarre
on va on va parler du ça m'étonne pas de
2 ans née d'une association bernard
montiel
[Rires]
hadmar capital et les très sérieux je
l'adoré je ne connais pas cette dame je
vous la donne a grillé ses bassines
argent pas vraiment la sensation je
trouve que les petites querelles david
laura sylvie vartan et tout ça il ya un
moment donné si vous voyagez génial
sylvie alem non c'est pas le problème il
pourrait y aller c'est pour de l'argent
c'est pour une association mais alors
qu'on l'aimé chacun mais ne croit pas
lui donne pas il donne aussi le ratio de
redone je le sais est ce qu'on peut vous
donner l'eau sa yamaha
perso ça fait chier a priori danemark a
su que j'ai eu tout à l'heure au
téléphone asus a arrêté d'appeler anne
marcassus mais l'or parce qu'on veut on
rigolera tu m'as d'accord ou
non d'après marca s'ils vont rien gagné
du tout il espère gagner un tout petit
peu si jamais la salle est remplie deal
place et on est loin du compte pour le
monde à combien l'art exact en septembre
comment dire combien ab pas encore ça va
démarrer là cette semaine s'il a fait un
crochet à la sauce on sait pas quand
c'est quoi mais ne sous-estimé pas la
qualité et l'intégrité de madame marque
acier alors jamais on sous-estimant anne
marcassus qui est extraordinaire et la
productrice également des [ __ ] dans
l'habitude des concerts de charité merci
les cherry dans le gps est aussi jarry
qui a donné une interview à rtl dans
laquelle ils dénoncent la discrimination
qui existe dans le milieu de la télé il
est revenue sur les remarques homophobes
qu'il a pu entendre et sur comment se
comporter lorsqu'on est gay hanter les
regarde au départ on me disait fais
attention tu es très efféminé tu sais
faut pas faire peur à la ménagère genre
nature des cas ouargaye son fuseau la
télé c'est pas le meilleur exemple de la
représentativité de l'acceptation et de
la tolérance on dit pourtant que c'est
un milieu très tolérant très gay
friendly notamment oui mais je crois et
gris gay friendly quant à une apparence
de bûcheron si tu es trop efféminé
c'est un peu gênant il faut que tu sois
un [ __ ] raisonnable voilà qu'il va se
battre au de bruit qui crie pas trop
fort aujourd'hui encore de penser qu'à
certaines émissions qui ne vous invite
pas à sauter un peu efféminé parfois je
crois qu'il ya des oui je crois qu'il ya
des gens que ça met mal à l'aise et
voilà qu'ils qui compte peut-être encore
quelques doutes pendant hésité alors il
faut que tu sois un [ __ ] raisonnable
c'est une phrase qui a énormément fait
parler ce week end c'est vrai que tout
on a repris nicolas pernikoff ça vous
choque est ce que c'est parce que vous
étiez pas con mine de rien mais qu'est
ce qu'un vieux raisonnable d'abord puis
de poser et puis avoir été en permanence
en mairie c'est une phrase que vous
auriez pu
mais ça existe pas peut-être qu'il ya eu
des peut-être qu'il ya des gens de
manière isolée qui ont pris des
décisions contre qui sont peut-être
homophobes au fond d'eux jean sérien la
télévision mais vous savez très bien
qu'arrêté on ne maltraite pas les
homosexuels ont dit pas à quelqu'un
d'être un [ __ ] résonna
alors quand même des chaussures adaptées
basse que par on il est trop efféminé ça
va pas plaire s'ils rentrent pas dans un
cas d'enfants après tu peux avoir
quelques conseils
non mais si par exemple ils sont
dangereux je connais mal jarry messi
sauter dans tous les sens à un moment
donné et qui pourrait je sais pas
parasiter le plateau et [ __ ] un peu le
bordel on pourrait lui dire non pas en
tant qu'homosexuel mais lui dire
calme-toi un peu détends toi parce que
tu es tu es très présent qu'il faut dans
tous les sens encore mais je ne vois pas
quel chien de la télévision dire arrête
et trop efféminé tu vas faire un martyr
je trouve
je vous dis je trouve hypocrite et je
tenais à l'homosexualité en télé pendant
des années et même surtout roma demander
de raser ma barbe a demandé d'être un
peu voilà des années on a demandé à des
animateurs de cacher leur homosexualité
parce qu'on a peur que ça fasse comme le
dit j'arrive fuir la ménagère et puis
regardez dans une émission de
divertissement prenait danse avec les
stars combien de saisons ils ont attendu
avant de mettre deux hommes qui dansent
ensemble parce que l'image peut
peut-être choquer des gens bien sûr
qu'il ya un malaise autour de
l'homosexualité évidemment mais il est
mal alors chez toi tu es tu as menti
nicolas ne me dit pas quand
j'écoute
on attendait
ils ont entendu deux types météorite
dans une piscine
ries qui disait que franchement si un
mec qui lui ai dit ça mais qui donne son
nom à la
salle du
fond ceux qui nous regardent sarata si
vous trouvez deux petites boulettes
n'hésitez pas à nous les envoyer vers la
entendu enchaîne par un peu trop noir ce
qui est un peu trop arabe un peu trop
près bien évidemment c'est tout le monde
le sait nicolas non mais c'est sur
vous et déraisonnable ça veut dire sobre
mais effectivement qu'on lui a suggéré
entre l'eire et ses mines est folle
perdue qui ouvent partout mais bien sûr
qu'on avait dit voit bien le dos ouais
quoique radine pas encana l'histoire il
a parlé quand besoin de la parole à
l'inhumation on lui a dit qu allah
l'histoire n'en fait pas trop soit ok
dans sa diversité mais c'est autre chose
c'est un oui mais réaliste mais c'est
sûr mais j'arrive jarry ce qu'il est en
train de dire là j'arrive par menteurs
quand il dit on va demander d'être des
trains entre guillemets un [ __ ]
raisonnable ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils veulent moi c'est moi ce qui
me gêne nico c'est que là je trouve un
peu hypocrite parce qu'en fait dans la
célèbre
[Rires]
justement et je trouve particulièrement
dans cette émission c'est que les gens
disent la vérité est enfin dit ce qui se
passe vraiment bien sûr viola est
justement jarry il a les couilles pour
le coup contrairement à toi
dans le milieu donc moi je trouve ça
génial il faut que tout le monde partout
on dise les choses et au moins on peut
arranger ce qui se cache jamais
s'arrêter m'a dit moi on m'a dit au
départ on may be plein de fois c'est un
animateur de bar mitzvah
bas bien sûr après voilà c'est avec pas
tant aimé giral de madame dans mes
matches non mais quand ils veulent et
sharp et déraisonnable ça voulait que ça
veut dire paix d acceptables pour la
maçonnerie parce que l'argent c'est
absolument terrible mais ça mais ça veut
dire quoi ça va être simplement qu'en
télé on n'a pas le droit d'être trop
alors tu es loin d'avoir un marketing
qu'une fois de temps en temps tu as
droit d'abord une grosse part d'avoir un
[ __ ] un peu comme andy je sais pas
grandiloquent et exubérant mais il faut
que ce soit un archétype acceptable par
tous et le trot en télé tu le sais très
bien ne fait pas semblant à chaque fois
on te diront
mais c'est plausible on veut pas des
gens trop veut pas de gens tout match ou
alors il en faut alors et les sociétés
comme nous par exemple ici par un voilà
on vous pourrez pas mettre que des
dépressifs on appris que raymond
qu'est ce qu'on pense à moi c'est moi ça
me dérange un peu quand une fois qu'ils
ont réussi ils se plaignent de ce qu'ils
sont de nature al-sisi tenax si pépé dtp
des
grands qui se plaint tout le temps qu'il
est [ __ ] mais reste comme ça tu es faire
le plein chantier vraiment mais là une
chance de bois texane abusif
mais ne me dis pas que tu aies [ __ ] je
veux pas savoir majan foot je veux que
tu présentes à la télé durée 6 0 c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont manqué de brider sa
personne et matthieu delormeau nous à
dix juste avant la pub attention je vais
me faire insulter suit ce qui se passe
pour ça fait 20 ans que la télévision
montrent des homosexuels totalement
caricaturaux ils font les queer il met
benjamin bove tu jettes une année
géniale je l'adoré si tu veux et great
de la capture dont ils font à
secretstory cabrillon benoît dubois
qu'on adore [ __ ] il écrit fur et à mesure
elle fait partie de notre île en écoute
moi bien ça fait 12 ans qu'on demande à
danse avec les stars que deux garçons
dansent ensemble et quand deux garçons
dans son ensemble qui dansent sébile al
hassani j'ai rien contre bill à la ceni
mais pardon un mec qu'a une perruque et
des fossiles je ne me reconnais pas dans
ce style de gaines chacun mais chacun a
son style et télévisa lui a choisi
d'avoir ce style mont saint jean d'illac
sommes extrêmement caricaturaux
totalement dit juste connu bilatérales
et c'est tout maintenant il est connu il
est coincé quand même on ne connaît pas
les noms alors là je suis pas d'accord
avec toi moi je n'ai pas une patte bilal
assadi parce qu'ils y parce qu'il est
homosexuel est prévu à la salle parce
que c'est une star parce qu'ils
arriveront à l'europe parce que
non là je suis pas ta faut que les gens
que tu vois la télévision se disent
tiens je reconnais le guet parce que
sans gain énorme annoncée bas qu'il est
gay qui cherchent du choix nier qu'il
est comme cela qu est pas surpris c'est
tout a lâché pas d'alluré gérald et
malek cherrad il ya des bons gars et des
mauvais mais on a plein de gay comme
laurent ruquier il est pas tout faire
marc olivier fogiel ton ami il n'est pas
tout match face à berne le problème
c'est que c'est toi qui nous pousse à
faire des listes de bong et ou de
mauvaise suivant qui son projet de vie
comme la télévision systématiquement et
dans toutes les émissions il faut
montrer des gays extrêmement
caricaturaux
ça amuse je rends parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on est encore présente il a muselé
jean stéphane bern il a mis des gens
mais c'est marrant tu prends de kavala
deux cas ça ça leur a pris 20 ans pour
dire qu'ils étaient gays y voilà c'est
tout il faut qu il faut pas du tout
quand tu es gay il faut pas du tout au
contraire devenir aseptisées mais il
faut demander à shekels se formater et
moi personnellement je te le redis je
suis choqué que dans danse avec les
stars par dont celui qui danse avec un
garçon cette année soit un gain gay qui
soit extrêmement caricaturale et c'est
facile c'est pas pour ça qu'il a été
choisi
désolé c'est pas pour ça qu'il a été
choisi mathieu je te jure mais comme
elle a non la nova tu te trompes de
l'ain tu te trompes d'exemple je
comprends maintenant quand même moi
j'adore bilal sani je me reconnais pas
comme gay nabil al assal imad mois les
autorités il a prévu de lancer parce que
c'est une personnalité qui vit là la
ceni c'est une personnalité on adore on
a envie de le voir danser moi j'ai envie
de vacances avec 12 ans comme on à tf1
que deux garçons dans son ensemble et
comme par hasard ils ont briki le gai
très caricatural parce qu'à la
télévision on le verra êtes ou cyril
brivet très connus vidal c'est une
énorme qualité il marche très fort sur
les 15 34 ans je suis désolé ils veulent
réagir ils veulent rajeunir leur alors
leur audience
le chou normal on n'aurait pas vu qu'il
était gay il l'aurait pas fait
contat à la balade des gens je pense que
mathieu est quand même le mieux placé
autour de 7 9 pour parler pour la cause
des non non pas du tout ça veut rien
dire si je suis désolé du tout en effet
dans la peau des gens on va du tout mais
les mâles mathieu n'est pas dans la peau
de bilal assadi des cadets au niveau des
choses que je vois sur twitter on n'est
pas sur la non mais à l'ol oui oui j'ai
même en parler mais on n'est pas là pour
jouer j'aurai alors que mathieu il est
là il en parle mais un sourire il va te
dise qui reçoit il a tout à fait le
droit mais jette pas d'accord oui mais
sur base sur bilal assadi n'a pas du
tout été choisi pour sa fille
je peux parler quand même - géraldine
elle donne son avis par exemple sur marc
olivier fogiel là vous parlera pour une
chose parce qu'en fait là on parle de
émission à peu près sérieuse l'on parle
de divertissement et le divertissement
mathieu a raison c'est vrai qu'on met
souvent des caricatures
ses mandants terminer là haut isabelle
fille se laissera plus de ma part en
propre filet laissait lui comme un
nouveau succès dans le coin comme bien
sûr
danser ensemble mais j'en fis janselme
et de 0,58 à danse avec les stars mais
où on veut absolument danse avec un
homme je suis homo j'ai envie de danser
avec une femme exactement non mais
sachez d'accord acquise à cet égard et
pas de caméra choqué une caméra on met
un mec qui a une perruque combien de
l'audience c'est mathieu est ce que tu
as déjà demandé des trucs temps aux
télécoms voilà parce qu'on a eu le
témoignage de jarry qui m'ont dit qu'il
fallait voilà qui voilà qu'ils soient y
voilà c'est ce qu'il a dit on a vu cette
on a vu ce qu'il a dit c'est vrai qui a
dit qu'il fallait qu'ils sont un peu
plus raisonnable dans son comportement
c'est ce qu'ils on lit est ce que toi tu
as déjà posé d'une honda déjà dit des
trucs comme ça bon match des émissions
où j'animais y avait des chroniqueurs
mais dit on m'a dit il ya trop de pdo
taux d'émission non oui oui il ya trop
de [ __ ] ou éloignent un ou deux de toi
parce que vous faites trop aidé l'un
proche de l'autre donc je les ai donné
un peu oui des choses comme ça oui ça ça
j'ai déjà entendu bon ça à la limite ça
m'a moins choqué samoa ah ouais ouais
oui bernard alors vous savez qu'en chine
les hommes efféminés sont bannis de la
télévision au foot déjà depuis 2010
mais c'est vachement sur elle dans le
sujet mais qu'il a été sur wikipédia
nous fait chier
tentures rfm oui et castaldi ya de
l'expérience
je pense que pas complètement tort et je
pense que dans la représentativité de
l'omo en télévision n'en est pas à ce qu
il parlait même temps il parlait de loft
story par les denrées dans l'octogone où
on a eu thomas dans le loft ne l'était
pas et qu'il dit pas du tout examiné il
a besoin d'un remède en thomas c'est le
premier communal qu'on ait fait en
télévision et en télé réalité c'était
dans le 2 n'était pas du tout fait mine
emea c'est vrai que l'animal on va
sentir depuis 30 ans et plus la cage aux
folles que les gens demandent que
quelqu'un de normal et cinq jours ça je
te rejoins complaire si absolument
absolument
que je n'ai rien contre les gays qui
sont cage aux folles mais c'est pas tout
légué on n'est pas que ça et on se
représente pas là-dedans voilà et je
suis désolé encore une fois 12 en
attendre on attend 12 ans pour que deux
ans deux hommes dansent ensemble et bien
le mec qui danse avec un autre il a une
perruque merde
la raison
je te jure que c'est un côté
générationnel mais aujourd'hui les
jeunes de 30 ans de 20 ans c'est
peut-être un tout petit peu plus âgés
que 20 ans ou 30 ans ils se
reconnaissent beaucoup d'ambiance rue
mais un rapport au maquillage par
rapport aux perruques je te promets gaza
libère la parole aussi de beaucoup de
jeunes qui ont un rapport par rapport à
leur identité de jeu te promets si si
c'est une vraie avec moi je peux
comprendre ce que dit mathieu c'est vrai
que quand à 12 ans pour qu'il y ait deux
homosexuels qui dansent ensemble il aura
peut-être voulu voir deux homosexuels
classe en costard
et très classe
présente lui n'est pas là pour insulte
au premier trimestre d'un gain annonce
avec un mec alors qu'il ait pas d
plusieurs fois donc forcément ils ont
raison mettez pas de bédié
il ya déjà eu des homosexuels dans danse
avec les stars et quittons ci avec des
filles qui étaient très contents
c'est parce que je suis homophobe
homophobes tiens je vais regarder belle
tombe sur deux mecs qui dansent ensemble
avec des perruques et des fossiles on
n'arrive pas à arrêter
mathieu je pense que s'il avait fini
deuxième ensemble pas de gay n'y a pas
de polémique effectivement on pouvait
faire doser des âmes ensemble
sommeillant aucune limite déjà volé n'a
pas de polémique mais je vous dis à bala
dans le ferry ça qu'il a des cheveux qui
déraille comprends très bien remis aux
propos limites julie guillaume chantant
je suis entièrement d'accord avec
monsieur je vais même aller plus loin
d'elle la ceni la représentation de miel
hassani c'est pas la représentation d'un
homosexuel s'est alors emparé
représentation d'une femme à ouvrir que
visuellement vous avez un homme qui
danse avec une femme un homme qui a les
cheveux longs gants alors représentée
comme une femme et je pense que pour
plein de gens et c'est la réflexion de
plein de chaînes de télévision
malheureusement l'image de deux hommes
avec une apparence d'hommes puisque
milana signé de la main bien sûr et deux
hommes qui dans son sang alors si ça
peut choquer la journée manga qui réagit
qui nous dit jean pigeon 7 voulez danser
avec un homme sérieux qu'ils avaient
résolu oblige il avait refusé et là pour
bilal il axe isaac 7 mathieu a raison
la nier non à ben ouais mais bien sûr
grâce à nous le dire à vous
si tu veux comme si tu vas voir rapide
tu dis ouais j'ai volé un truc
il faut se réveiller ma chérie